we will not sit forward our arms and
once the country collapse that is what
Julius malema has said he's the head of
the eff opposition party and he's
standing here in the middle of this
crowd and he's going to be or he is
marching towards Cyril ramaphosa's
office where he says he's going to
demand that the president resigns he
says as far as he's concerned this
natural shutter and has been a success
because many businesses have got opened
and many people have not gone to other
certainly in Pretoria we've seen a lot
of places have stayed shut today the
other issue they're Marching for is
about the economy and the High Cost of
Living and the electricity crisis some
areas this country can go for up to 10
hours a day without power and people are
frustrated the government says they're
doing everything they can try and
resolve the issue in South Africa
including a newly appointed electricity
Minister but people are saying what good
is this person going to do given that
it's taken many many years for the
country to fit its electricity prices
the president has come and he said that
he's going to do everything he can to
turn around the economy and fix all the
issues affecting the country including
electricity South Africans can only wait
and see if that's going to happen